I first saw this pattern that I'm about to
show you in a question on the math stack
exchange what the user had been doing
was playing around with data in polar
coordinates the pattern that we'll look at
centers around plotting points where both
of these coordinates are a given prime
number it initially looks quite random
after all primes are famous for their chaotic and
difficult to predict Behavior but when you zoom
out what you start to see are these
very clear Galactic seaming Spirals
and what's weird as some of the
arms seem to be missing and zooming
out even further those spirals
give way to a different pattern
[Music]
these many different outward pointing rays